qual é o lápis pra pintar sua corro
claro que se diz o que é aceito
contradiz quando o desenho vai me
abordar pedir a minha pele pintar meu
lugar
se vejo um produto mais reprodução nariz
afinado traços de marcação a china em
branco passado sem o meu retrato que
tenho de errado cadê representação não
me ia só então mais isso ficou para trás
mas as marcas estão aqui para lembrar os
traços da minha carne fazem do meu
diário cresceu adversário para se
levantar
eu quero traz histórias eu quero ser um
zumbi
quero minhas memórias quero me ver ali
eu quero traz histórias
eu quero ser dão dará e ver todas as
glórias de vida igualitária tomará
tomará a a rever todas as glórias de
vida igualitária a tomar a tomar ou e
ver todas as glórias de vida e
igualitária
boa noite café obrigada é meu nome é
time larga como ela falou é eu decidi
começar a cantar essa música porque eu
vi ela é eu vi uma notícia na tv de um
menino de 7 anos que chegava professora
e dizia que ele não tinha o menino era
negro e ele não tinha um lapso da cor da
pele dele
quando eu li essa notícia eu vi que ela
né é que eu me identificava um pouco com
ela porque eu passei por algumas
situações 10 e tive a inspiração de
fazer essa música e compor essa música e
como o tema de hoje é mostre se eu achei
interessante começar mostrando meu
trabalho começar mostrando a minha
verdade né pra que a gente possa
conversar
eu não sou palestrante profissional eu
não costumo fazer essas coisas eu
costumo cantar e falar menos né às vezes
uma piadinha entre um show e outro mas é
quando eu recebi o convite fiquei
pensando que eu podia trazer para vocês
que eu podia falar pra vocês já que eu
me meti em tanta coisa na minha vida eu
vou até ler aqui no papel porque às
vezes se esquece é eu sou publicitária
eu sou musicista sou compositora beach
maker designer produtora cultural
locutora atriz e eu aprendi a fazer tudo
isso na minha vida pra pagar as minhas
contas trabalhando com arte o artista é
tudo vagabundo foi essa frase que eu
escutei ao longo da minha vida
por trabalhar com arte no interior do
paraná é é as pessoas que dizem isso
elas acham que o artista ele fica só
dentro de casa a esperando sentado no
sofá esperando aquela aquela inspiração
chegar para que ele possa mostrar alguma
coisa para o mundo e fazer alguma coisa
é essa frase artista tudo vagabundo ela
foi ela saiu dos nossos pais né
mas hoje nossa na nossa geração ela se
transformou num meme é aquele m
se tudo der errado eu largo que eu tô
fazendo vou vender arte na praia né por
causa do mesmo por causa da milena mas
passa dia passa hora e o artista ainda
visto como uma última escolha
profissional como a última saída como se
fosse um sinônimo de derrota
e hoje eu tô aqui pra falar pra vocês
que eu posso ser tudo mas - derrotado
não eu não sou famosa não eu não viajei
o mundo inteiro não eu não gravei um
clipe caneta e eu não participei do do
arquivo confidencial faustão ainda mas
eu trabalho com arte no interior do
paraná
eu acordo cedo todos os dias eu vou pra
agência é como diretora de criação eu
desenho quase todos os dias seja
digitalmente ou num papel ilustrando nos
finais de semana eu vou para os bares
faculdades festivais
tarô discotecar e quando eu não tenho um
espaço que me proporcione trabalhar com
o tipo de música que eu trabalho eu
produzo os eventos
hoje produz eventos por quase todo o
paraná
em alguns locais do brasil e e eu
trabalho com isso divulgando a música
afro-brasileira brasilidades cultura
lgbt e cultura hip hop
porque eu acho que quando a gente
trabalha com a nossa verdade quando a
gente faz aquilo que a gente acredita a
gente trabalha com uma explosão a gente
trabalha com mais vontade e aquilo nos
volta mais aqui nos beneficia mais medo
como eu tô sentindo um pouco agora por
estar falando com vocês
medo é o que mais dá a sensação de
rejeição é o que mais dá principalmente
quando a gente fala sobre temas que têm
uma abordagem sobre as minorias hoje em
dia mas isso eu falo mais pra frente eu
só sei que trabalhar com arte não tem me
dado ao salário de 15 mil 20 mil reais
mas o prazer eu fazer o que eu gosto
viajar de graça por alguns locais do
paraná e do brasil
puro receber essa mídia gratuita dos
jornais das revistas vinha atrás pra
saber o que eu gosto para saber sobre a
musa música autoral para saber o que eu
penso e ainda pagar as minhas contas
isso não tem preço e o que eu acho mais
importante pra falar sobre essa
trajetória de 29 anos e o que me deu
coragem de fazer tomar essa decisão
viver com uma coisa é certa forma hoje
em dia arriscada é ter fé na arte no meu
trabalho e em tudo que eu me esforce
crer nas coisas acreditar nas coisas
é o que mais me motiva crer é a base de
todas as ligações que a gente tem
nós temos que crer na nossa família nós
temos que criar nossos amigos nós temos
que crer na nossa religião
nós temos que crer em nós mesmos crer em
mim é o que me trouxe aqui hoje eu
cresci numa família de fé minha voz
marina alves de paula é mãe de santo
desde que eu nasci eu aprendi sobre
cultura afro brasileira e eu aprendi
também a respeitar a fé alheia porque já
que minha religião como eu sou bandida
recebe tanto preconceito eu aprendi
desde o começo a respeitar a fé do outro
não foi nada obrigado na verdade ea
obrigação partiu da minha mãe para que
eu fizesse catequese para que quando eu
crescer se eu tivesse um paralelo na
minha vida eu deveria escolher o
catolicismo seguir a religião da minha
família não sei das coisas e também é
minha voz nunca chegou pra mim e falou
assim a menina você quando crescer vai
ter que ser macumbeira nunca teve essa
abordagem na verdade foi uma coisa
entrando calmamente na minha vida eu
lembro dela colocando a mão na minha
cabeça de benzendo quando eu nem sabia
falar e hoje que ela me aconselha que
ela me ensina ter equilíbrio que ela me
ensina a encontrar a paciência e
encontrar o meu destino
quando a gente crê quando a gente tem fé
a gente tem força dentro de si a gente
consegue enfrentar o mundo de frente e
em alguns casos é um pouco difícil eu
por exemplo acabei levando umas porradas
da vida é conforme as vivências não
acontecendo
quando eu era criança né é além de
artista também sou negra gente vocês
estão vendo aqui na minha frente e eu
recebi os melhores apelidos possíveis
desde os mais simples como pretinha
até os mais pesados como preto
encardida como cabelo bombril
eu até lembro de um chamado milkshake
que eu acho super criativo porque eu
acredito que seja a a assunção do
chocolate com com leite mas é a gente vê
que a criança criativa dependam da via
que ela absorve né
tanto no pólo negativo como pólo pólo
positivo ela tem a criatividade depende
que os pais passam ela e do que ela
absorve na minha adolescência eu vi o
menino apanhando por ter beijado como eu
tive meus privilégios também de estudar
em colégio particular
eu mesmo estudando um colégio particular
mesmo tendo seus privilégios
eu era a única negra da sala e naquela
época isso não era sinônimo de beleza na
minha faculdade
o fato de ser negra de ser lésbica isso
também foi um sinônimo de exclusão
social pra mim e às vezes até aqui está
meu há alguém aqui também olhando
falando eta mas deus dos deuses nunca me
deixaram só
minha fé em mim mesma não se abala e a
gente usa rejeição usa os nãos da vida
como combustível artístico na minha vida
fé e arte andam de mãos dadas e todo
artista tem que estar preparado para
ouvir muito não e continuar seguindo em
frente
e considerando bem todos nós não é mesmo
todo artista criando seu próprio sonho
porque seu próprio sonho é seu ganha pão
e quantos não já pararam uma ideia sua
quantos não fizeram você desistir de
auto profissionalmente como qualquer
área da sua vida
quantos não fizeram você parar de sonhar
hoje eu tô aqui na frente de vocês para
dizer que eu existo e além do mais que
eu resisto e que a voz me ensinou
além de ter fé de que nos orixás e de
ter respeito de ter caráter
ela também ensinou acreditar em mim as e
destemida como vento e andar por onde eu
quisesse e principalmente ter coragem de
transformar os meus sonhos em realidade
assim como as nuvens os sonhos parecem
sempre distantes mas basta um pouco de
esforço de fé para que a gente consiga
se aproximar do céu não deixe de
acreditar
motumbá e obrigado
[Aplausos]